oh I wasn't clean oh heaven's sakes
um
oh yeah yeah
tricked me you just
use the test you used to know when the
test was gonna be then they come out
with something called out of competition
testing what is this within the rules
yeah this is not within the protocol I'm
trying to cheat within the rules that's
right I was trying to cheat within the
rules yeah that's right vulnerable yeah
well they got performance enhancing
those are positive terms then they call
it drug at the end to make a it's
medicine right this is legal and
appropriate medicine that does make you
better all medicine makes you better or
it's not met like I would never go to a
doctor and go doc I feel great can you
bring me down a notch of courses to make
you better they said that to me I was
able to commission here and they said
did you know this could give you an
advantage I said guys I wanted to have
taken it
an advantage and they sat there they
were they were dumbfounded they couldn't
believe this response like well I can't
believe your questions of course it of
course it's meant to make you better how
good how good is it oh it's great like
what is it because a lot of people I
think look at this and they go okay and
maybe it makes you stronger but it's not
going to make your chin last longer and
it's not going to make your punches
sharper and it's not going to make you
learn Jujitsu true so yes it gives you
an advantage but can you explain the
type of Advantage well straight is huge
but you know the the training for that
sport is so difficult I used to wake up
every single day compressed yeah that's
what it is I mean I would literally wake
up depressed knowing what I have to do
today before I can get back into bed it
was the most defeated feeling I would go
to bed sometimes where I could barely
get into bed I'd wake up the next
morning that was a distant memory yeah
the recovery was incredible and then
guys try to do it as a badge of honor
well I only took it so I could train
harder which then you're complimenting
yourself because I was just such a hard
worker like well there is there is a
little bit of a truth to that but uh
yeah bigger stronger faster in that
order but they got some performance
since chance was like if the world
understood what LeBron did like other
basketball players will hear what LeBron
does and go well yeah but that doesn't
matter right you're it's like a baseball
player you're hitting a stick out of the
way it doesn't matter it's like no no if
you knew what these performance answers
did then you would know why it does
matter what you're thinking there's only
one we have the same drug guy if you
will I know exactly what he's doing but
there's only one golfer please tell
there's only one golfer I'm not going to
but there's there's only one golfer that
follows the big three The Big Three is
EP video growth hormone testosterone
that's the Lance Armstrong diet there's
one golfer but it's Tiger Woods like yes
it does matter people set all time
doesn't matter John Daley wanted it it
matters trust me that it matters
view matters it's the reason LeBron
takes it it matters and if other
basketball is understood what it did EPO
increases your red blood cells which
gives you endurance so you can play all
game long you can shoot in the fourth
mode
in your red blood cells okay I got you
it's the king of performance enhancers
so you would prefer that especially in a
fight sport to anything EPO is King does
that ever give you the stamina yes
Tour de France so that fifth round
energy is the human body is not made to
do the Tour de France I mean the people
that set that up are inhumane so of
course you have to go of course it's
supernatural people that you you're
they're forcing them to take now that
you're not going to take pets are you
still on yeah yeah uh well so
testosterone it's all around
testosterone so you can just take
straight testosterone I'm currently
taking something called HCG which is
human uh chloronic gynotropin but it
just UPS your natural to it's all about
testosterone is that a peptide no
I've been reading about those I don't
know I will get into them I mean I'm
into learning about them that's what I
hear the Hollywood guys
I'm gonna do the same peptides yeah yeah
well I'm hearing about them yeah I'm
hearing about them I just don't know if
they're as good as the as the regular
stuff like why take a peptide if you
could just get growth hormone or if you
could just go to the source yeah if you
could just get testosterone I'm a little
confused on that and do you worry about
affecting your nuts at all no well and
so again you're talking about use versus
abuse like um I've never heard a doctor
and that's an open statement you can go
to the the same Forbes that's telling
you that Floyd made 250 million come on
man you're not that foolish are you come
on 250. it's just I'm being serious it's
just a number after yourself yeah you
know what I mean yeah I hear you but
who's putting that on I mean who is the
guy that but if he made 250 what did
this guy put on that brought the whole
thing together come on man yeah this is
insane
here's what I would share with you
though and I've completely forgot what
you're talking about Force the same
Forbes would talk about thank you very
much thank you very much because this is
a challenge I'm gonna make a big
challenge here but I've never seen a
doctor there's any doctor you go to the
Internet yeah will tell you that
steroids are bad or the performance
enhancers are bad it's abuse abuse we're
having a totally different conversation
I would be an advocate for testosterone
use but testosterone abuse and that's
the problem with human nature here
you're supposed to have two well if I
should have two four is better I'll take
nine that's the problem you send
somebody home with it which is why most
of the these hormone Labs you've got to
come in every week I'll give you the
shot myself I can't trust you if I give
it to you yeah that's right I can't
trust you to go home and take this
appropriately
um listen you know we know that you're a
busy man you gotta fly we got to talk
about Bellator 291 oh man what do you
think about that can I set this up here
that's your camera oh well but but for
you guys here's one thing they don't do
in our Sport and I I did and I'm gonna
I'm gonna name drop but Laila Ali yeah I
gotta interview lay Lawley one time I
did the Celebrity Apprentice with her
yeah she comes to the hotel and I get an
interview I gotta talk about Rhonda a
little bit but that was a big deal at
the time but one thing that Layla said
is she said I wish I would have done the
Olympics and the reason she had is she
was a multiple time world champion and
she retired like 28-0 I'm making numbers
I mean it's something like this and she
said but in my heart I never felt it I
knew what my promoter was doing I knew
that I was training my ass off and they
were grabbing a girl from the bar
from the local club that made a building
up yeah I knew that I was training the
way that my father had taught me to do
and this girl had only sparred once in
her life and so I'm knocking these girls
out and she said if I would have gone
through the Olympics that would have
said an architecture where I would know
I was the best and that's one thing we
don't have in the sport of MMA and
boxing we don't have a competitive
architecture in place so Scott Coker is
the only promoter really with the guts
to hold a tournament it's not about the
fight that he thinks the biggest or
who's going to run their mouth or who
can get the most meteor who can politic
you all you eight guys say that you're
the best I'm gonna put you eight in a
tournament we'll start in the
quarterfinal straight line bracket
winner gets the belt winner gets the
main event winner gets a million dollars
and the eight baddest dudes step forward
he got four guys that are former world
champions to step forward one guy just
got pulled out of a tournament named
Sydney Outlaw they put Brett Primus in
who's a former world champion so now
they got five world champions not to
mention the favorite so they got five
world champions and none of them are the
favorite are supposed to win it McKee's
supposed to win the whole thing but
we're going to start this off we got
uzman versus Benson Henderson the UFC
champion uzman is khabib's cousin
undefeated 16 the reigning Champion I
know I'm jumping around but there's a
lot of moving Parts here and I think for
any promoter Scott Coker is the one in
this case that has the courage to put a
straight line bracket and bring an
actual architecture it's not about who
talks the best it's not who's got the
fanciest promoter behind the scenes you
eight guys starting the quarterfinals
play this thing through till we're done
and one of you gets the belt at a
million bucks and they're going to start
on March 10th and look guys if you're
betting on this weekend's Bellator
fights or if you're betting on
absolutely everything you know that
you're using betonline.ag you already
know if you're watching this podcast you
listen to this podcast that's the one
that we rock with plain and simple and
I'm going to tell you exactly why
because they're gonna match 50 of your
initial deposit bonus up to a thousand
dollars that means you put up into a g
in there if you put the G you're getting
500 extra to gamble with why would you
not do that if you're already gambling
why don't you take free money to gamble
this is an absolute no-brainer
betonline.ag make sure if you're
throwing down while you're watching some
dudes throw down it's with betonline.ag
makes you use that promo go flagrant to
get that extra free cash and let's get
back to the show so the story is the
million bucks store is the million and
the title
title
it's just something so authentic it was
just something scary so sincere about
the way your your face now yeah
it makes sense because I think that was
it the pfl did like a million dollar
tournament thing I paid attention sure
I'm like wait there's a million dollars
on the line and for me the million
dollars changes someone's life for sure
that's what a million does right it's
like okay there are these guys that
they're struggling they're fighting for
how much money who [__] knows and
ideally they don't play up how rich they
are because the more Rich they seem in
the promo towards the million the more
useless the Millions for sure but if all
these guys are working at Home Depot and
then come out afterwards they can barely
make their car payments and all of a
sudden a million dollars I mean you see
what happens in the UFC when they give
them the 50 000 bonuses and the people
start to cry I can move my family to
where I live it's beautiful so the
million I love but how do we get people
to be into each one of those characters
yeah how do you do it yeah well that's
an interesting thing I mean you bring up
a really good point but one thing to
look forward to is just that you know it
really is chest not Checkers so when one
guy gets done the quarter files he knows
who's next and if he doesn't he at least
knows what fight yeah well so now he's
got a rough idea of also when when this
fight's gonna be I'm gonna be sitting in
the front row anyway and where this is
going to go and I got to be part of a
tournament I will tell you it is very
different from a competitor's standpoint
when you know who you've got wait it's
not the same day no it's not the same
day okay I've done those things I mean
way back that's crazy I used to do eight
men One Day by the time I came along it
was it was four man and then you know it
went down I mean at the end aren't your
hands just just so sore so tired I've
only got I've had two four-man
tournaments so so two guys in one day
and I would say yes the next day was
just amongst the when you feel it the
most amongst your and now I couldn't
even imagine I couldn't even that was
normal back then I mean my mother and
father took me to the airport like you
know put me on the plane with this kiss
on the chicken and I'm calling him from
a pay phone to tell them how I did it
yeah I couldn't even imagine agreeing to
fight two men and one night or like
hoyce Gracie did with three but you
anyway that's the point of the term
that's the whole point of the Grand Prix
is it's a straight line bracket there's
no politics coker's got eight guys that
claim they're the best well they're all
going to get the same chance who do you
think you uh who do you got uzman has
never lost or brother nomagomatov has
never lost yeah um I think you have to
look at that but uh I mean to count on
AJ McKee I watched AJ McKee beat Darren
Caldwell in less than a minute so you
know yeah and those aren't even you know
Primus is my own teammate and so you
know I mean there's a few guys I guess I
I gotta watch my tongue a little bit but
it's uh I mean it's stacked man I'll be
the last guy to count Vincent Henderson
now the world champion he's gonna be in
the Hall of Fame someday of course now
do you think that the dagestanis are are
juicing no
no Islam uh IV situation yeah that's a
sticky rule I mean it would it would be
a lot to answer that question that is a
sticky rule with USANA and Islam had the
legal right to use an IV the question is
what went in the eye that's right that's
right and how many milligrams he used
and um
yeah because they would have tested for
what went in yeah and that would have
showed up yeah but they can't test for
how much water was ingested right yeah
yeah it gets a little bit more complex
in terms of the assay and the science on
that I think that Islam stands right now
is is to not even comment it seems good
Ivy
um I I don't think he's wrong to do that
he did IV and I and I don't add him to
talk mines but you know you're fighting
with your clothes off and you you can we
we can take photos and zoom in on that
he did IV but but I'll just share with
the world that it that doesn't mean it
was a violation even if it was a
violation whoever this nurse is that
spoke up I mean shame on her what a big
mouth do you do that in America that
take your license away I mean you've got
hip on all sorts of other stuff goes to
his hotel she gets she juices them and
then she goes and tells the other Camp
when he flies out of town that was a
scumbag move I mean she's acting like
she is the hero of the story and The
Whistleblower she's a scumbag
well she hasn't come forward right she's
not acting like anything because she's
kind of she's but she shared information
to share information and what is that
that's hip there's a HIPAA law there's
HIPAA in America they did this over in
Perth the foggiest idea what the rules
are but in America yeah she would have
violated his rights definitely would
have
and he might have disclosed it to asada
we also don't have information that
didn't do that and on top of that and
then it's the milligram I mean there's a
lot that goes into this and the only
reason I say that is there's not gonna
be an investigation there's there's no
smoke here yeah this isn't an ongoing
story if he wants to make this dramatic
by saying he didn't do it and having
other people zoom in and see the vein
and see that he did and there's more
more power to him but he's not in
violation of anything and if you want to
know who's the skunk of this story it's
the woman that went to the room took the
money and out of him the next day
I mean how dumb would you have to be to
be on Islam's team and do something
illegal in a foreign country with some
random number and wear a short sleeve
shirt the next day yeah like I don't
know it just seems so in the home
country of the guy you're fighting yeah
it seems it almost seems as if like
either they didn't know they couldn't
add liquid up to x amount or they did it
up to the league right because it's so
blatant it's so Bland yeah sure and it's
so easily discredit it's not only you
but like now you're going to khabib's
Legacy I mean there's a dominance from
the dyestinians who are looking for a
reason why for sure they're asking the
question I asked you immediately which
was are they on steroids why are they so
good what's so different about these
guys they're looking for cheating it
seems like they have an internal honor
that I can't imagine they'd want to
disrupt that yeah it just seems like a
very loose situation take your own IV
person if he was over hydrated yeah how
much has that changed there was outcome
of the match how much did that have to
do with him winning in my opinion it's a
guy that's tried every performance in it
not much I mean ibean doesn't do much
Lance Armstrong when he beat all the
tests and don't forget Lance never
failed the test he just confessed to
Oprah right he just bitched out and said
that he did it he never actually failed
the test but the way Lance would beat
those tests as he would I be so you you
owe you IV it out of your system and
it'll flush it fast I'm talking about a
few hours it will be flushed and you
will pass anything you can get a call
that day and be like no problem oh so
they called him for the IV not the tests
testosterone but he still hasn't told
the world how he did it I could tell you
but he hasn't told the world but he told
the world how he didn't get caught and
he didn't get caught because he would
flush it with an IV so usada comes out
they're worried that people know this
people didn't know it that's the mistake
that people we actually didn't know who
sought a smart and dust of how to beat
them but then they tried to claim that
they could test plastic particles and
we'll know if you iv'd over this and
that part they're they're bluffing um
now if you say yes I used an IV well you
can only use up to 30 milligrams great
then I use 29. that no they don't know
if you put in 60 they don't know if you
put in 200 they don't know what you but
they claim that they know but they they
don't so basically any fighter can beat
a drug test yes
it's a little bit more complicated but
but yes there are some big problems with
the IV not to mention you let's use IV
and I'm making numbers up but it is 30.
you can you can have 30 ml I can do 30
ml take it out and put 30 ml on this arm
I can go back and put another third in
this arm the way that the rule is
written I can only have 30 at a time
what's the time a minute a day a session
oh wow every time this nurse comes in my
room what is a time and that's never
been challenged but it has a challenge
and they haven't collected the language
because we saw it doesn't know what to
do they don't know what to do because
they can't catch you so yes they told
the world how to beat them and do you
think most pro athletes are doing this
even outside of the UFC not fight Sports
not most pro athletes like if you go
into an NFL locker room yes yes I mean
they look ridiculous
um but no I don't I don't think most pro
athletes know very few in basketball I
mean that's why I bring LeBron up like
there's very few in basketball there's
only one that I know of in in uh you
know
it works was my only point it wasn't to
embarrass LeBron